did you know that devops is one of the
fastest growing areas in Tech according
to a recent report companies are
investing more in devops than ever
before in fact the global devops market
is expected to reach 15 billion dollars
by 2026 and with the demand for skill
devops professionals On The Rise now's
the perfect time to start or Advance
your career in this exciting field
devops is all about breaking down silos
between the different teams that work on
software development
as a devops professional you get to work
on some of the most exciting and
Innovative projects in the industry but
becoming a devops professional isn't
just about having technical skills you
need to have a deep understanding of the
entire software development process from
planning to deployment the devops career
roadmap is a path that professionals can
follow to grow their skills and
expertise in devops it typically starts
with foundational knowledge and builds
upon that with more advanced concepts
and techniques so here is a breakdown of
the different stages and the devops
career roadmap
first is the basic understanding of
software development the first step in
the devops career roadmap is to have a
basic understanding of software
development this includes knowledge of
programming languages database system
and software design principles to learn
more you can check out the link
[Music]
second is familiarity with devops tools
once you have a basic understanding of
software development you can start
learning about devops tools like Jenkins
ansible and docker these tools are used
to automate software development testing
and deployment and they are essential
for any devops professional to learn
more you can check out the link
third is collaboration and communication
skills in addition to technical skills
developed professional also need strong
collaboration and communication skills
we need to work closely with developers
testers and other stakeholders to ensure
that software is delivered on time and
meets quality standards
continuous integration and delivery as
you become more experienced in devops
you will need to master continuous
integration and delivery this involves
automating the software development
process so that new code is tested
integrated and deployed quickly and
efficiently
and fifth is cloud infrastructure as
more companies move their applications
to the cloud devops professionals needs
to have expertise in Cloud
infrastructure this include knowledge of
cloud platforms like AWS Microsoft Azure
and Google Cloud platform to explore
more about this you can check out the
link in the description
and finally leadership and strategy as
you advance in your devops career you
may need to take in leadership roles and
develop strategies for your organization
this requires a deep understanding of
business processes and the ability to
Align Technology initiatives with
overall business goals so if you are
ready to take the next step in your
devops career sign up for the devops
killer course today you'll also gain
hands-on experience with popular devops
tools like Docker kubernetes and Jenkins
you'll gain the skills and knowledge you
need to succeed in this exciting and
dynamic field
you can learn it at your own pace on
your own schedule and from anywhere in
the world that too for free invest in
your future with the devops skill up
course thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here